while the big bang theory's storyline
was never particularly hard to follow
it can still be helpful to have an
overview that's why we're running down
the story of leonard sheldon
howard raj penny amy and bernadette for
anyone who just can't get enough
the big bang theory takes place in
pasadena california and the action is
confined
almost entirely to a few apartments it
centers around the misadventures of
physicists
leonard hofstetter and sheldon cooper as
well as their fellow caltech scientists
neighbors and romantic partners sheldon
is a theoretical physicist with a genius
level iq
who has trouble grounding himself in the
real world at the beginning of the
series
he holds an incredibly condescending
view of non-scientists and believes
himself to be an unparalleled
intellect leonard has a much kinder view
of the world
however both he and sheldon have trouble
interacting with ordinary people
particularly women throughout the series
romantic partners and other people bring
the two of them
and their friends astrophysicist raj
kuthrapali and engineer
hallard walowitz out of their respective
shells the catalyst for this
introduction to the outside world
is waitress and aspiring actress penny
who moves in across the hall from
leonard and sheldon in the pilot episode
she makes friends easily and her
proximity to the scientists helps to
drag them out of their insular lives
sheldon and leonard were already living
together before the series began
and thus plenty of resentment already
exists between them when the pilot airs
sheldon is frequently a tyrant
stubbornly refusing to adjust his
routine
or consider the feelings of others this
leads to frequent fights during which
leonard seeks refuge in penny's
apartment
one such fight happens at the beginning
of the season 3 episode the staircase
implementation which goes on to reveal
the story of how
sheldon and leonard first came to live
together leonard is shown seeking a
roommate after first arriving in town to
work at caltech
he meets sheldon who quizzes him on
sci-fi trivia before allowing him to
enter
original series over next generation but
picard over kirk
correct you've passed the first barrier
to roommate hood
at this point the apartment features a
spare living room that
indicates an otherwise occupied mind
instead of the couches and chairs that
the main characters spend the majority
of their time gathered around
the layout is simply lawn chairs around
a card table when leonard enters his
future bedroom
he discovers that sheldon's former
roommate has painted die
sheldon dye on the wall as a parting
gift undeterred and in need of a room
leonard decides to stay he gets an early
glimpse of sheldon's temperament when
he's forced to sign an incredibly
detailed roommate agreement that will be
used to arbitrate many future disputes
this origin story leads penny to ask the
obvious question
why is leonard still living with sheldon
leonard reveals that despite sheldon's
cold demeanor he's frequently defended
his roommate from potentially harmful
situations
for example there was the time that they
discovered that leonard's former
girlfriend joyce kim was a north korean
spy attempting to get information about
an experimental rocket fuel that leonard
was developing
leonard could have easily been facing
treason charges but sheldon promised to
defend him should the government come
looking
there was also the time that leonard's
enthusiasm for his rocket fuel
experiments nearly turned deadly
egged on by howard and raj they
attempted to use his fuel in a rocket
that howard had built but leonard got
the proportions wrong and accidentally
created a bomb
sheldon then correctly calculated how
long they had before the fuel detonated
he pushed a panicking leonard away from
the mixture placed it in the building's
elevator and closed the door right
before it exploded
unquestionably saving leonard's life
sheldon promised to keep mom about the
cause of the destroyed
elevator which remained broken for
almost the entire series
sheldon's ability to protect his friends
and the multiple times that he kept
leonard from serious harm demonstrate
his true value as a roommate
leonard sheldon howard and raj all have
trouble deviating from their regimented
schedules
they've divided their weeks into a
routine of visits to the comic book
store
gaming nights and tv viewing parties but
this pattern is eventually broken up by
romantic interests
over the course of the series leonard's
life is shaken by his on-again off-again
relationship with penny
howard is reeled in and reformed by his
girlfriend and eventual wife bernadette
raj and sheldon meanwhile proved to be
tougher nuts to crack
raj is clinically terrified of women his
phobia is so intense that even though he
desperately wants to be in a
relationship
he loses the ability to speak in the
presence of any woman
he's eventually able to get over this
intense fear after he dates a
dermatologist named emily who proves to
have a particular taste for gory movies
they kind of turn me on and play
as with most parts of life sheldon is
the notably difficult to budge when it
comes to romance
his changes in the area are gradual and
hard-won
but they do indeed come thanks to the
efforts of amy farah fowler
she is remarkably similar to him and
probably the only person on the show who
can fully understand his worldview
she had previously avoided romantic
relationships her entire life to focus
on her work in neurobiology
sheldon did pretty much the same thing
but unlike sheldon
amy had always desired a romantic
partner so she turns her relentless
planning energy and desire for a
regimented schedule toward the concept
of marriage
sitcoms tend to depend on familiarity
and a slow sense of growth
as viewers come to love the characters
the big bang theory adhered to this
strategy over the course of 12 seasons
there's romantic tension early on
between leonard and penny
who seem to be constantly on the verge
of a relationship
once they do couple up the ups and downs
of their journey carry the series
forward
their relationship builds explodes and
recombines throughout the show's run
as penny guides leonard and his friends
toward a happy life outside their bubble
the couple fall apart in the fourth
season but leonard ultimately realizes
that he cares enough for penny to pursue
a relationship
they nearly break up again at the end of
the eighth season while traveling to las
vegas
but they then make an impulsive decision
to get married and see it through even
after leonard admits that he kissed a
co-worker
rather than wrap up the season with
their wedding in typical sitcom fashion
the ninth season begins with them
married and explores the hard work of
keeping it together as they deal with
leonard's infidelity they end the season
planning a wedding do-over with family
and friends and they remain together
through the series end
sheldon's frequently callous attitude
toward amy's feelings leads the two of
them to split up and reconcile several
times throughout the series
they go on their first date in the
season 4 premiere and eventually get
married in the season 11 finale
after sheldon finally realizes that
there's no one else on earth he could
envision spending the rest of his life
with
sheldon isn't the only character who
shows significant growth on his path to
married life
as howard starts the show as an
unrelenting creep whose off-putting
behavior sabotages any attempt at a
relationship
howard where are you going i'm going
home to live my
creepy pathetic life this is even true
in the early stages of his relationship
with his eventual wife bernadette
she breaks up with him in season 4 after
finding out he had cyber relations with
his fellow world of warcraft players
but they ultimately reconcile and she's
able to pull him out from under the
thumb of his domineering mother and help
him become his own man
they go on to have a daughter and a son
and both of them realize their
professional goals
howard travels to space as an astronaut
while bernadette earns a phd in
microbiology
it's worth noting that among all the
main characters raj
is given the least to do considering how
the show develops characters through
relationships his perennially single
status leaves him nowhere near as much
room to change as everyone else
that doesn't mean he's entirely static
though for much of the series he suffers
from selective mutism
whenever he gets near women he loses the
ability to speak due to overwhelming
anxiety
his mutism can go away when he's drunk
or at least thinks that he's drunk
eventually he grows out of this
condition there's also occasional
speculation that raj
is gay thanks to his style of dress love
of women targeted entertainment
and constant close companionship with
howard weirdly enough
though he's often seen having more
success with women than howard
he's actually able to win over some
ladies via his uncomfortable silence
he almost ends up married in the final
season as the show finds him in a
relationship with a woman named anu
but that storyline comes to an end when
she's offered a job in london
and he opts to stay behind in los
angeles
throughout the series penny keeps the
other characters grounded
most of the other women are brought into
the show via their connections to penny
and the men become fully functioning
adults thanks in great part to her
frequent lessons about the real world
just like other characters penny also
matures as she settles into a
comfortable adulthood
she follows her friend bernadette into
the world of pharmaceuticals leaving
behind her precarious life as a waitress
and aspiring actress for the
solidly middle class existence of a
sales representative
the possibility of penny becoming a
mother bookends the series as she's
shown in a flashback at one point
fretting over a pregnancy test that test
way back when was negative which greatly
relieved her at the time
the accumulated changes in her life and
a much more stable existence are
reflected in the way that she reacts to
a similar situation
at the very end of the series well i
can't get more pregnant
we'll see about that the big bang theory
closes with quite a few conclusions and
at least one beginning
leonard and penny finished the show
celebrating a positive pregnancy test
ecstatic at the idea of being parents
raunch's romantic life is left up in the
air but it's implied that he's gone from
someone who couldn't even speak in the
presence of women
to someone who might now be dating a
world famous actress howard and
bernadette have been settled down in
marriage for a while so the finale more
or less just lets them be
amy and sheldon achieve their lifelong
goal of a nobel prize in physics
highlighting the way that it's always
been about the work for them however
after a big blow up with everyone else
over sheldon's incredible stubbornness
he delivers the most shocking moment of
the finale by realizing that there's
more to the world than himself
from the nobel ceremony stage he thanks
his family and then acknowledges his
friends for their incredible patience
i was under a misapprehension that my
accomplishments were mine alone
nothing could be further from the truth
though the big bang theory has come to
an end
fans can still get their fix as cbs has
continued to mine sheldon cooper for
ratings gold
in the form of the prequel series young
sheldon it focuses on sheldon's early
life with his family in texas
and don't be surprised if it ends up
sticking around just as long as its
predecessor
as it's been a top 10 ratings hit its
first three seasons
for anyone who wants to catch a glimpse
into how the big bang theory was made
and the genuine love the cast has for
each other there's a behind the scenes
documentary
unraveling the mystery which aired the
same night as the series finale hosted
by johnny galecki
and kaylee cuoco it features clips from
the series reflections on particularly
beloved moments
and a look at how the sitcom sausage was
made for 12 seasons
and of course the original series itself
provides plenty of material on its own
to devour for anyone who's in the mood
for a re-watch
it's there for whenever the mood is
right check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
you